part of Al jazeera's undercover
investigation includes an airport
security manager at the Zimbabwean civil
aviation Authority explaining how this
smuggling is carried out
yeah
that is my area
for me
what you are okay
it will also help you make some changes
if he for example you are taking money
we need to know how much you are taking
usually for money is
it's about five percent of what you are
taking
but if you are taking a Precious
Minerals won't diamond
the prices I have
Alexander James who's part of the Al
Jazeera team uncovering the story says
this type of corruption involves
different airports Banks and top
government officials
not all of the smuggling at the airport
happens in Hidden compartments of
baggage or private airport officials
many of the Smugglers moving through the
airport carry all the right paperwork
but that's because the export deals that
they have are secured by a bribery and
Corruption or through political
influence they're they're corruptly
acquired export deals and to all intents
and purposes that is gold smuggling it's
true to say that Zimbabwe's political
conditions make it incredibly vulnerable
to smuggling a recent report found that
1.5 billion dollars are lost every year
through gold smuggling but really what
we build over the course of this
investigation is an international
picture of the corruption and ultimately
it's all about control and whether that
is controlling an airport through
officials there
um who can control what goes in and out
or as we discover in South Africa if you
can control a bank too
you can move much much more money
we're going to bring in Eddie cross he's
a former opposition Member of Parliament
in Zimbabwe he's joining us from Harare
very good to have you with us sir what's
more striking about this what's
happening how it's happening or the
scale of it
well to be and to be frank the two
episodes that have been flighted by Al
Jazeera so far have really not had
anything that we weren't aware of I mean
there's fairly well known uh that a high
proportion 70 of the gold
Market in Zimbabwe has smuggled across
our borders and the cigarettes marking
cigarette trading activities smuggling
activities of the two rudlin boys is
also a well-known feature of of regional
economics if I can call it that
I I think the I think the the shocking
point of the whole
um story for me has been to the
allegations about the involvement of the
monetary authorities in Zimbabwe and the
fact that this is money laundering on a
fairly large scale
um and it it might in influence the
international authorities we've just
been taken off the gray list
uh South Africa has just been put on the
greatest uh because they thought that we
had improved the way we were managing
our foreign exchange flows and trade
flows and this is a very damaging from
that point of view I think also the
impact on on Dubai Dubai is now the
largest gold market in the world and
they won't be happy at all with these
allegations of them being in receipt of
gold which has no real origin
and I think the world gold Community is
moving towards a time when they go into
ban such gold movements similar to The
Blood Diamond industry so I think it's
it it's very serious
um none of us at in Zimbabwe are are
saying it isn't
um the question is what to do about it
and how to regularize the situation
and uh that I think needs attention the
other thing I just thought I'd say to
your your colleagues I watched this
episode two tonight
and the allegations about the
involvement of the president I think are
very very shaky
um I don't believe that he's involved in
in the sort of activity indirectly and
this allegation that two hundred
thousand dollars buys an appointment to
see him is just plain rubbish
um let me ask you a time forgive me
I'm so sorry for interrupting you but I
do want to pick you up on one thing or
I'll get you to to expand on one thing
if this is so intrinsic to society where
does the responsibility for oversight
lie does it lie with the banks who have
perhaps failed in that regard or does it
lie with successive governments who are
aware of the situation and either cannot
or will not do anything about it
I think it lies a government
ultimately
um
you can really blame the banks I think
the banks will take very Swift action
against the individuals who've been
identified tonight
um but ultimately you know I've been
absolutely mystified as to how 70 tons
of gold try Transit the South African
border and we never see anybody being
arrested
and that simply points to collusion at
the highest level in South Africa it's
the same with cigarette smuggling they
catch the odd Consignment but we know
that cigarette smuggling on a very large
scale takes place across the the border
with South Africa the industry is
massive and billions of Rand are
involved and I do not understand why the
authorities who clearly must know about
this uh why they don't don't take more
effective action I want to ask you about
the fence sorry go on please yeah I was
going to say on outside of the fence in
Zimbabwe I think we have a real
obligation to put our house in order and
to do it quickly and I know we know how
to do we know what to do and it wouldn't
be difficult and it wouldn't cost us any
money we'd actually make money out of
the deal but you know that's a political
decision
yeah I want to ask you about that
because our report was saying there that
it's estimated there's about 1.5 billion
dollars that's lost every year to the
economy clearly that is money that any
country would be glad to have how do you
break the cycle in this because if it's
reaching from the the lower levels right
up the way to the the highest accolones
as you were talking about where do you
break that cycle and start to change the
system
right I think the 1.5 billion is an
underestimate substantial underestimate
Transparency International reckon we've
lost 100 billion US dollars since
Independence 42 years ago that's more
than two billion dollars a year
um I think the losses through this kind
of activity run to many billions of
dollars but look at look at the Gupta
scandal in South Africa I mean my
goodness gracious the scale of that and
the audacity
um you know is it's just mind-blowing
and let me ask you about it let me ask
you about a point that you made earlier
on you said that the banks were likely
to take very Swift action as a result of
what they've been learning we've had
already in the report that some of them
are are already addressing it and yet
you did mention that you were not able
to work out how the government was
actually going to respond to this what
would be the best way for the government
to respond to this
well I can tell you that the so-called
um Pastor the the the the the the the
guy who claimed to be a Christian
Christian Pastor has been stripped of
his diplomatic passport in fact he's had
his passport removed from him and uh the
president has stripped him of all all
status uh he might in fact fail jail
time
um I know that uh one of the big white
uh gold Traders has fled the country uh
with his family
and I would imagine that there will be
other elements inside that story against
which action will be taken
but you know the the fundamental problem
for African States
can we identify them as just plain
African you know I mean maybe it's a
global problem this question of
corruption and when it takes when it
takes root the Chinese I think have the
the right approach uh corruption is a
criminal offense and it is subject to
the the the most severe punishment uh
that's in the book and I think we've got
to do the same thing here Eddie cross we
appreciate you joining us another thank
you very much indeed for your time sir
thank you
thank you very much
you can watch the second of our
four-part series gold Mafia smoke and
mirrors the full episodes coming up in
Al Jazeera at 20 GMT